hey I'm Issa Rae and I play Easter D I'm
Kendrick Sampson and I play Nathan
Campbell
so Nathan roasted Issa that's a big deal
why does he deserve a shot even though
it wasn't the easy way he still chose to
come back and do it the hard way it has
not used his words
because he's trying to earn his way back
in so he's not trying to be aggressive
with it he's trying to make sure that
you knew that he was sorry and then you
know tried to creep back in whenever she
would allow him to do so why do you do
but I meant like you know gradually come
back and doesn't have to say just
steadily and gradually okay Lawrence was
here before Nathan in the most recent
iteration of their relationship Issa
cheated and warrants forgave her so that
feels like a clean slate Nathan got a
lot going on he's still coming into his
own doing well he accepted
responsibility and he's working on
himself he's going terribly he's got
this into barbash but is he ready for a
relationship
at this point for season five who knows
what's gonna happen Jeana I do
you